How can I help you today?
I just got here today,...
...and I'd like to rent a car while I'm here.
Very good! You have come to the right place.
We have the best rental cars in the city.
That's good to hear!
What kinds of cars are available?
We have many kinds.
What kind of car would you like to rent?
A small car with good gas mileage, if possible.
Okay, our Novas are very popular.
Here, take a look at this picture of one.
Yes, that looks good.
And you say it gets good gas mileage?
Very good. The best of any of our cars.
Okay, I'll rent one of those then.
Is it possible to rent a convertible?
I'm sorry, but those are not available in a convertible.
No problem. I'll just take the regular sedan, then.